herzlich willkommen liebe zuschauerinnen
und zuschauer hier bei der übertragung
des ausserordentlichen gebietes aus
anlass der korona epidemie von papst
franziskus auf dem petersplatz in rom
der platz ist leer
er ist seit 10 märz gesperrt für
besucher gläubige pilgern und der papst
wird ziemlich alleine begleitet von
seinem zeremonien meister und wenig
wenigen mitwirkenden gleich hier ein
besonderes gebet sprechen und den segen
urbi et orbi erteilen
das ist etwas ganz außergewöhnliches
denn eigentlich erteilt der papst diesen
segen nur an weihnachten und ostern und
direkt nach der wahl eines neuen papstes
das zeigt die besonderheit dieses
augenblicks hier in rom
der erste teil der feier hier bei
strömendem regen in rom wird auf dem
sogenannten sa krato stattfinden das ist
der vorplatz direkt vor der fassade des
petersdoms bei papst franziskus ist der
päpstlichen zeremonienmeister monsignore
guido marini
im namen des vaters und des sohnes und
des heiligen geistes beginn gehabt
franziskus dieses gebet lasst uns beten
allmächtiger und barmherziger gott sie
unseren schmerz und unsere bedrängnis
tröste deine kinder und öffne unsere
herzen für die hoffnung damit wir mitten
unter uns deine väterliche gegenwart
spüren
darum bieten wir durch ihn jesus
christus deinen sohn unseren herrn und
gott armen
es folgt ein text aus dem
markus-evangelium aus dem vierten
kapitel in dem es um den sturm auf dem
meer geht
[Musik]
am abend dieses tages sagte jesus zu
seinen jüngern wir wollen ans andere
ufer hinüber fahren
[Musik]
sie schickten die leute fort und fuhren
mit ihm in dem boot in dem er saß weg
und andere boote begleiteten ihn
plötzlich erhob sich ein heftiger
wirbelsturm und die wellen schlugen in
das boot
so dass es sich mit wasser zu füllen
begann der aber lag hinten im boot auf
einem kissen und schlief sie weckten ihn
und riefen meister kümmert es dich nicht
dass wir zu grunde gehen
[Musik]
da stand er auf drohte dem wind und
zeigte zudem see schweiz sei still und
der wind legte sich und es trat völlige
stille ein
[Musik]
er sagte zu ihnen warum habt ihr solche
angst habt ihr noch keinen glauben
[Musik]
da ergriff sie große furcht und sie
sagten zueinander
wer ist denn dieser dass ihm sogar der
wind und das meer gehorchen
[Musik]
am abend dieses tages
so beginnt das eben gehörte evangelium
seit wochen scheint es als sei es abend
geworden tiefe finsternis hat sich auf
unsere plätze straßen und städte gelegt
sie hat sich unseres lebens bemächtigt
und alles mit ohrenbetäubender stille
und einer trostlosen lehre erfüllt die
alles im vorbeigehen lernt es liegt in
der luft
man bemerkt dass an den gesten die
blicke sagen es wir sind verängstigt und
fühlen uns verloren wie die jünger des
evangeliums wurden wir von einem
unerwarteten heftigen sturm überrascht
uns wurde klar dass wir alle im selben
boot sitzen alle schwach und
orientierungslos sind aber zugleich
wichtig und notwendig denn alle sind wir
dazu aufgerufen gemeinsam zu rudern alle
müssen wir uns gegenseitig beistehen
auf diesem boot befinden wir uns alle
wie die jünger die wir aus einem mund
angsterfüllt rufen wir gehen zugrunde so
haben auch wir erkannt
dass wir nicht jeder für sich sondern
nur gemeinsam vorankommen
vielleicht finden wir uns selbst in
dieser geschichte wieder schwieriger ist
es da schon das verhalten jesu zu
verstehen während die jünger natürlich
alarmiert und verzweifelt sind befindet
er sich am heck in dem teil des bootes
der zuerst untergehen
und was macht er trotz aller aufregung
schläft er friedlich
ganz im vertrauen auf den vater es ist
das einzige mal im evangelium das wir
jesus schlafen sehen
als er dann auf geweckt wird und wind
und wasser beruhigt hat wendet er sich
vorwurfsvoll an der jünger warum habt
ihr solche angst habt ihr noch keinen
glauben
versuchen wir zu verstehen worin besteht
der glaubens mangel der jünger der im
kontrast steht zum vertrauen jesu sie
hatten nicht aufgehört an ihn zu glauben
sie flehen ihnen ja an
aber schauen wir wie sie ihn anrufen
meister kümmert es dich nicht dass wir
zu grunde gehen kümmert es dich nicht
sie denken dass jesus sich nicht für sie
interessiert dass es sich nicht um sie
kümmert im zwischenmenschlichen bereich
in unseren familien ist es eine der
erfahrungen die am meisten weh tut wenn
einer zum anderen sagt bin ich dir egal
das ist ein satz der schmerz und unser
herz in wallung bringt das wird auch
jesus erschüttert haben
denn niemand sorgt sich mehr um uns als
er in der tat als sie ihn rufen rettet
er seine mutlosen jünger der sturm legt
unsere verwundbarkeit bloß und deckt
jene falschen und unnötigen gewissheiten
auf die wir bei unseren plänen projekten
gewohnheiten und prioritäten gebaut
haben
der sturm macht sichtbar wie wir die
dinge vernachlässigt und aufgegeben
haben die unser leben und unsere
gemeinschaft nehren erhalten und stark
machen
der sturm entlarvt alle unsere vorhaben
was die seele unserer völker ernährt hat
weg zu packen und zu vergessen all die
betäubungs versuche mit scheinbar
heilbringenden angewohnheiten die jedoch
nicht in der lage sind sich auf unsere
wurzeln zu berufen und die erinnerung
unserer älteren generation wachzurufen
und die uns so der immunität berauben
die notwendig ist um den schwierigkeiten
zu trotzen
mit dem sturm sind auch die stereotypen
masken gefallen mit denen wir unser ego
in ständiger sorge um unser eigenes
image verkleidet haben und es wurde
wieder einmal jene gesegnete gemeinsame
zugehörigkeit offenbar der wir uns nicht
entziehen können dass wir nämlich alle
brüder und schwestern sind
warum habt ihr solche angst habt ihr
noch keinen glauben
dein wort heute abend trifft und
betrifft uns alle
in unserer welt die du noch mehr liebst
als wir sind wir mit voller
geschwindigkeit weiter gerast und haben
das gefühl stark zu sein und alles zu
vermögen in unserer gewinnsucht haben
wir uns ganz von den materiellen dingen
den anspruch nehmen lassen und von der
eile betäuben lassen
wir haben deinen anruf nicht angehalten
wir haben uns von kriegen und weltweite
ungerechtigkeit nicht aufrütteln lassen
wir haben nicht auf den schrei der armen
und unseres schwerkranken planeten
gehört wir haben unerschrocken
weitergemacht in der meinung dass wir in
einer kranken welt immer gesund bleiben
würden jetzt auf dem stürmischen meer
bitten wir dich wach auf herren warum
habt ihr solche angst habt ihr noch
keinen glauben
herr du appelliert an uns du appelliert
an den glauben nicht nur an den glauben
dass es dich gibt sondern an den glauben
der uns vertrauensvoll zu dir kommen
lässt
in dieser fastenzeit erklingt ein
eindringlicher ruf kehrt um zu mir von
ganzem herzen mit fasten weinen und
klagen
du rufst uns auf diese zeit der prüfung
als eine zeit der entscheidung zu nutzen
es ist nicht die zeit seines urteils
sondern unseres urteils die zeit zu
entscheiden was wirklich zählt und was
vergänglich ist die zeit das notwendige
von dem zu unterscheiden was nicht
notwendig ist
es ist die zeit den kurs des lebens
wieder neu auf dich herr und auf die
mitmenschen auszurichten und dabei
können wir auf das beispiel so vieler
weggefährten schauen die in situationen
der angst mit der hingabe ihres lebens
reagiert haben
es ist das wirken des heiligen geistes
das ermutige und großzügige hingabe
größten und geformt wird
es ist das leben aus dem heiligen geist
das in der lage ist zu befreien
wertschätze werte zu schätzen und zu
zeigen die unser leben von gewöhnlichen
menschen die gewöhnlich vergessen werden
gestaltet und erhalten wird
die weder in den schlagzeilen der
zeitungen und zeitschriften noch sonst
im rampenlicht der neuesten shows stehen
die aber heute zweifellos eine
bedeutende seite unserer geschichte
schreiben
ärzte krankenschwestern und pfleger
supermarktangestellte reinigungspersonal
betreuungskräfte transporteure
ordnungskräfte ehrenamtliche helfer
priester ordensleute und viele viele
andere die verstanden haben dass niemand
sich allein rettet angesichts des
leidens an dem die wahre entwicklung
unserer völker gemessen wird entdecken
und erleben wir das hohe priesterliche
gebet jesu
alle sollen eins sein
wie viele menschen üben sich jeden tag
in geduld und flößen hoffnung ein
und sind darauf besorgt keine panik zu
verbreiten sondern mitverantwortung zu
fördern
wie viele väter mütter großväter und
großmütter lehrerinnen und lehrer zeigen
unseren kindern mit kleinen und
alltäglichen gesten wie sie einer krise
begegnen und sie durchstehen können
indem sie ihre gewohnheiten anpassen den
blick aufrichten und zum gebet anregen
wie viele menschen beten für das wohl
aller spenden und setzen sich dafür ein
gebet und stille dienst
das sind unsere siegreichen waffen
warum habt ihr solche angst habt ihr
noch keinen glauben
der anfang des glaubens ist das wissen
das wir erlösung bedürftig sind
wir sind nicht unabhängig
allein gehen wir unter wir brauchen den
herrn sowie die alten seefahrer die
sterne haben wir jesus in die boote
unseres lebens ein
über geben wir ihm unsere ängste damit
er sie überwinden wie die jünger werden
wir erleben dass wir mit ihm an bord
keinen schiffbruch erleiden
denn das ist die gotte denn das ist
gottes stärker alles was uns widerfährt
zum guten zu wenden auch die schlechten
dinge
er bringt ruhe in unsere stürmer
denn mit gott geht das leben nie zu
grunde
der herr fordert uns heraus und inmitten
des sturms lädt uns ein solidarität und
hoffnung zu wecken und zu aktivieren
die diesen stunden in denen alles
unterzugehen scheint festigkeit halt und
sinn geben erwacht
um unseren oster glauben zu wecken und
wiederzubeleben
wir haben einen anker durch sein kreuz
sind wir gerettet
wir haben ein ruder durch sein kreuz
wurden wir freigekauft
wir haben hoffnungen durch sein kreuz
sind wir geheilt und umarmt worden damit
nichts und niemand uns von seiner
erlösenden liebe trennen kann
inmitten der isolation in der wir unter
einem mangel an zuneigung und
begegnungen leiden und den mangel an
vielen dingen erleben lasst uns erneut
die botschaft hören die uns rettet er
ist auferstanden und lebt unter uns der
herr ruft uns von seinem kreuz aus auf
das leben das uns erwartet wieder zu
entdecken auf die zuschauen die uns
brauchen und die gnade die in uns wohnen
zu stärken zu erkennen und zu ermutigen
löschen wir die kleine flamme nicht aus
die niemals erlischt und tun wir alles
dass sie die hoffnung wieder entfacht
das eigene kreuz anzunehmen bedeutet den
mut zu finden alle widrigkeiten der
gegenwart anzunehmen und für einen
augenblick unser lechzen nach allmacht
und besitz aufzugeben um der kreativität
raum zu geben die nur der heilige geist
zu wecken vermag es bedeutet den mut zu
finden räume zu öffnen in denen sich
alle berufen fühlen und neue formen der
gast freundschaft brüderlichkeit und
solidarität zuzulassen
durch sein kreuz sind wir gerettet
damit wir die hoffnung annehmen und
zulassen dass sie alle möglichen
maßnahmen und wege stärkt und das sie
unterstützt die uns helfen können uns
selbst und andere zu beschützen den
herrn umarmen um die hoffnung zu umarmen
das ist die stärke des glaubens der uns
von der angst befreit und uns hoffnung
warum habt ihr solche angst habt ihr
noch keinen glauben
liebe brüder und schwestern von diesem
ort aus der vom felsen festen glauben
petri erzählt möchte ich heute abend
euch alle dem herrn anvertrauen und die
muttergottes um ihre fürsprache bitten
die das heil dieses ihres volkes und der
stern auf stürmischer see ist von diesen
colonnaden aus die rom und die welt
umarmen komme der segen gottes wie eine
tröstende umarmung auf euch herab
herr segne die welt schenke gesundheit
den körpern und den herzen trost
du möchtest dass wir keine angst haben
doch unser glaube ist schwach und wir
fürchten uns du aber herr über lasst uns
nicht in stürmen sagt zu uns noch einmal
verrichtet euch nicht und wir werfen
zusammen mit petrus alle unsere sorge
auf dich denn wir wissen du kümmerst
dich um uns
nach der ansprache von papst franziskus
beginnt ein zweiter teil dieser feier
hier auf dem petersplatz
franziskus verlässt seinen platz auf dem
sakko und vor dem wir fassade des
petersdoms wurden 2
[Musik]
man sieht sie hier 2
eine ikone und ein kreuz aufgestellt die
hier in der stadt rom
in verschiedenen kirchen verehrt werden
die man hierher zum petersdom gebracht
hat das ist zum einen die marien ikone
salus populi romani teil des römischen
volkes vor dieser ikone wird franziskus
jetzt zunächst innehalten und beten
während der chor
auf latein symptom präsidium unter
deinen schutz und schirm
[Musik]
aus
unter deinen schutz und schirm fliehen
wiro heilige gottes gebären verschmähen
nicht unser gebet in unseren nöten
sondern erlöse uns jederzeit von allen
gefahren wo die glorreiche und gewinne
der jungfrau
dieses byzantinische bildnis wird von
vielen römern in besonderen nöten immer
wieder aufgesucht
es steht normalerweise in der basilika
santa maria maggiore in rom und zieht
viele gläubige viele römer an die in
sorgen sich an maria als fürbitten de
bei gott wenden
franziskus steht nun vor einem kreuz aus
dem vierzehnten jahrhundert das
sogenannte westkreuz das normalerweise
in der kirche samt cello also im herzen
der altstadt steht dort hat es der papst
auch schon am 15 märz besucht und dort
gebetet
1522 wurde es während der pest den
prozessionen durch rom getragen und
wird immer wieder auch von römern
besucht
wenn sie in besonderer note
beten
[Musik]
[Gelächter]
der papst begibt sich in das atrium des
petersdomes dort beginnt der teil der
andacht des gottesdienstes der eine
eucharistische anbetung enthält das ist
eine typische katholischen frömmigkeit
form bei der sich gläubige zum gebet vor
einer geweihten hostie versammeln
die ist meist in einem ganz kostbaren
gefäß ausgestellt auf einem altar einer
sogenannten monstranz
[Musik]
ich wollte
harms stehen in diesen tagen und auch
bei dieser feier zwei dinge im
mittelpunkt das eine ist dass trost
spenden denen die unter dieser
besonderen situation leiden seien es die
kranken seien es die angehörigen der
verstorbenen zugleich dann auch das
gebiet all die sorgen und nöte mit
hineinzunehmen in das gebet vor gott
aus dem petersdom herausbringt ein pater
die monstranz mit der geweihten hostien
[Musik]
die katholiken bekennen dass jesus
christus als sohn gottes in diesem stück
brot dauerhaft und leibhaftig
gegenwärtig ist
und das in einer messfeier von einem
priester konzentriert wurde der chor
singt dorothee devote gottheit tiefer
bauten das ist ein hymnus den der
kirchenlehrer thomas von aquin verfasst
hat im 13 jahrhundert als das fest
fronleichnam eingeführt wurde
[Musik]
dort verbauten betend nach dir
unter diesem zeichen bist du wahrhaft
hier sie mit ganzem herzen schenk ich
dir mich ihn weil vor solchem wunder ich
nur armut bin
augen mund und hände täuschen sich in
dir doch des wortes botschaft offenbart
die ich mir was kurz angesprochen
nämlich glauben an er ist selbst die
wahrheit die nicht trügen kann einst am
kreuz verhüllte sich der gottheit glanz
hier ist auch verboten deine menschheit
ganz beide sieht mein glaube in dem
brote hier wie der tscheche rufe ich
herr zu dir
[Musik]
si
kann ich nicht wie thomas schauen die
wunden rote bete ich dennoch gläubig du
mein herr und gott tief und tiefer werde
dieser glaube mein fester lasst die
hoffnung treu die liebe sein denkmal das
uns ma ned an des herrn tot
du gibst uns das leben so lebendig brot
werde gnädig nahrung meinem geist du
dass er deine wollen koste immer zu
[Musik]
mo
gleich dem pelikane stabs du jesu main
was in deinem blut gemisch von sünden
rhein schon ein kleiner tropfen sind
alle schuld bringt der ganzen erde
gottes heil und holt jesus den verbauten
jetzt mein auge sieht stelle mein
verlangen dass mich heißt durch blut
lasst die schleier fallen einst in
deinem licht dass ich selig schauer
herr dein angesicht
[Musik]
die katholische frömmigkeit kennt diese
form der anbetung in stille vor dem
allerheiligsten der geweihten hostie die
stille in der sich der betende die
betenden in ihren anliegen an gott
wenden
ihre bitten vortragen
die bitten der menschen werden jetzt
dann gleich auch in form eines wechsel
gebets einer litanei hier ausgesprochen
von einem lektor eine litanei eine art
fliegendes gebet bittgebet an gott
für alle diejenigen die vielleicht
später hierzu der feuer dazugekommen
sind papst franziskus hat zu einem gebet
eingeladen sich mit ihm zu vereinen auf
dem petersplatz ein besonderes gebet aus
anlass der korona pandemie er wird am
ende dieses gebetes außer der reihe
außerordentlich den segen urbi et orbi
spenden und möchte so einen moment des
gemeinsamen gebets weltweit schaffen
vermittelt über fernsehen internet die
sozialen kommunikationsmittel radio
weltweit sind die menschen in diesem
moment verbunden um hoffnung zu schöpfen
in einer für die welt außergewöhnlichen
situation
cisco sieht hier seinen ort und seine
aufgabe gut zu machen
die sorgen der menschen mit
hineinzunehmen in die gebete in die
gottesdienste die auch in diesen tagen
hier im vatikan stattfinden aber wie
überall ohne die beteiligung einer
gemeinde sind immer nur wenige
mitarbeitende anwesend und über
fernsehen internet kommt dann die
gemeinde zusammen
wäre die opel interessenten in christus
ein wahrer gott und wahrer mensch
wahrhaft gegenwärtig in diesem heiligen
sakrament wir beten dich an du unser
gott mit uns retter treu und reich an
erbarmen wir beten dich an du könig und
herr über schöpfung und geschichte
gebeten dich an du sieger über sünde und
tod
wir beten dich an du freund der menschen
auferstanden und lebendig zur rechten
des vaters gebeten sich an
ein geborener sohn des vaters zu unserem
heil herabgestiegen vom himmel
wir glauben an dich du himmlischer arzt
der du dich hinab beust über unsere not
wir glauben an dich und du opferlamm
dass sich oft um uns vom bösen zu
erlösen
wir glauben an dich zu guter hirt der
das leben hingibt für die herde die du
liebst
wir glauben an dich du lebendiges brot
und heilmittel der unsterblichkeit der
du uns das ewige leben schenkt
wir glauben an dich
von der macht des satans und den
verführungen der welt liebe befreiung
vom hochmut und der anmaßung ohne dich
auskommen zu können
befreie unser herr von der liste der
angst und der beklemmung befreie uns
vorher von der ungläubigkeit und der
verzweiflung befreiung von
hartherzigkeit und der unfähigkeit zu
lieben befreien uns vorher
von allen übeln die die menschheit
quälen bewahre uns vor hunger not und
egoismus bewahre uns vor krankheiten
epidemien und der angst vor den
mitmenschen bewahre uns vor
zerstörerischem wahnsinn gnadenlosem
streben und gewalt bewahre uns vor
täuschungen falschen informationen und
der manipulation der gewissen bewahre
uns
sie auf deine kirche die die wüste
durchquert größte unser herr sie auf die
menschheit die erstarrt ist vor angst
und beklemmung tröste uns oh herr sie
auf die kranken und sterbenden die von
der einsamkeit niedergedrückt werden
tröste uns herr sie auf die ärzte und
die im gesundheitswesen arbeiten die
durch mühsame arbeit erschöpft sind
tröste uns herr sie auf die politiker
und die in der verwaltung tätigen die
die schwere laster entscheidungen tragen
größte umso höher
in der stunde der prüfung und der
ohnmacht sender uns deinen geist o'hare
in der versuchung und der
zerbrechlichkeit sender uns deinen geist
o'hair im kampf gegen das böse und die
sünde sende uns deinen geist in der
suche des wahren guten und der echten
freude sende uns deinen geist vorher in
der entscheidung in dir zu bleiben und
in deiner freundschaft sender uns deinen
geist
wenn die sünde uns niederdrückt öffne
uns für die hoffnung wenn der hass unser
herz verschließt öffne uns für die
hoffnung wenn der schmerz uns heimsucht
öffne uns für die hoffnung o'hair wenn
die gleichgültigkeit uns angst macht
öffne uns für die hoffnung wenn der tod
uns vernichtet öffne uns für die
hoffnung o'hair
[Musik]
nach einem kurzen gebet des papstes wird
kardinal comastri gleich den segen urbi
et orbi ankündigen
[Musik]
mit der rauch des feuers und der
weihrauch aufsteigen so sollen die
gebete aufsteigen gott
[Musik]
sakrament der liebe gottes leib des
herrn sei hoch verehrt mal dass uns mit
gott vereinigt brot dass unsere seele
nährt blut in dem uns gott besiegelt
seinen bunt der ewig währt lob und dank
sei gott dem vater der das leben uns
verheißt seinem wort dem ewigen sohn der
im himmels brot und speist
auch der bau der höchsten liebe sei
gelobt der heilige geist armen
[Musik]
lasst uns beten
herr jesus christus im wunderbaren
sakrament des altares hast du uns das
gedächtnis seines leidens und seiner
auferstehung hinterlassen
gib uns die gnade die heiligen
geheimnisse deines leibes und blutes so
zu verehren dass uns die frucht der
erlösung zu teilen würden der du lebst
und herz ist in ewigkeit
ich sein opa disco carina string kündigt
nun an mit dem segen urbi et orbi
auch ein ablass verbunden ist also der
nachlass von zeitlichen sünden strafen
einen solchen applus können die
gläubigen gewinnen die über radio
fernsehen und andere
kommunikationsmittel verbunden sind
es folgt nun gleich der segen urbi et
orbi durch papst franziskus er segnet
mit der monstranz
der die geweihte hostie die geweihte
hostie ist in dieser form wurde der
segen urbi et orbi
selten vielleicht noch nie gespendet
[Musik]
mit sicherheit wurde dieser segen aber
noch nie gespendet über einem leeren
petersplatz
das ist neu und in einem gewissen sinne
symbolisiert das was hier gerade
passiert das was die menschen in den
meisten ländern dieser welt in diesem
moment erleben die geburt verbunden über
die sozialen kommunikationsmittel aber
auch zugleich alleine
es folgt eine akklamation
gepriesen sei gott gepriesen sei sein
heiliger name gepriesen sei jesus
christus wahrer gott und wahrer mensch
gepriesen sei der name jesus
gepriesen sei sein heiligstes herz
gepriesen sei ein kostbares blut
gepriesen sei jesus im allerheiligsten
sakrament des altares gepriesen sei der
heilige geist der tröster gepriesen sei
die erhabene gottesmutter die aller
selige jungfrau maria gepriesen sei ihre
heilige und unbefleckte empfängnis
gepriesen sei ihre glorreiche
himmelfahrt
gepriesen sei der name der jungen frau
und mutter maria gepriesen sei der
heilige josef ihr reinster bräutigam
gepriesen sei gott in seinen engeln und
heiligen
[Musik]
lobt den herrn alle völker mit diesem
vers der aus dem psalm 117 stammt geht
die feier hier auf dem petersplatz in
der vorhalle des petersdoms langsam
ihrem ende entgegen
[Musik]
der priester bringt die monstranz mit
der geweihten hostie zurück in den
petersdom wo sie dann die hostie in
einem tabernakel aufbewahrt wird
[Musik]
pabst franziskus
legt die liturgischen gewänder ab und
zieht sich dann auch in den petersdom
zurück
damit sind wir am ende dieser
außergewöhnlichen feier dieses
außergewöhnlichen gottesdienstes
im vatikan
die korona pandemie hat
dazu geführt dass in der ganzen welt die
menschen
an diesem abend zusammengekommen sind um
mit dem papst zusammen zu beten zu beten
für die betroffenen zu beten dafür dass
die
helferinnen und helfer die an vielen
stellen in vielen ländern im einsatz
sind kraft unterstützung bekommen
der vatikan hat heute angekündigt dass
der papst auch die ostergottesdienste
feiern wird aber ohne gläubige die
gottesdienste finden im petersdom statt
der traditionelle kreuzweg der am
karfreitagabend normalerweise mit
tausenden gläubigen am kolosseum gebetet
wird wird in diesem jahr auch auf dem
petersplatz
stattfinden und so wird dies ein ganz
anderes osterfest seien ganz andere k
und ostertage die hier in rom gefeiert
werden
mit
den blick auf das pestkreuz
verabschiede ich mich von ihnen ich
bedanke mich dass sie in der vergangenen
stunde mit dabei sein
mit dabei waren bei diesem
außergewöhnlichen gottesdienst mit dem
papst in rom wünsche allen einen schönen
abend und alles gute
[Musik]